I want to talk about my skateboard
so I thought it'd be fun to every now
and then show off some of the personal
things that I have here in my office and
get you a little bit of the story behind
it first of all happy sunday morning
it's a morning for me and I'm a little
tired but excited to be here with you
guys one of the things that when people
walk in my office he always comment on
is my skateboard i thought i'd tell you
guys a story so the reason why this is
here is old this very old skateboarder
that has a little bit too much dust i'ma
probably right now is this is the first
thing that I ever bought with my own
money and kind of saved up for when I
was a kid at how old like eight nine ten
eleven somewhere in there you know money
that i got from allowance or from my
newspaper route or whatever I would
usually put into candy and toys and just
spending it all the time spending
spending spending not that I not that I
you know had a lot of money but I never
really saved up for anything and then I
saw this skateboard at Canadian Tire & K
entire is a retailer in in Canada itself
automotive and outdoor kind of stuff and
so this skateboarder I want to say it
was like 40 bucks $40 wow that's so much
and I begged my parents mommy daddy
please get me this keyboard I really
want this skateboard I wanted so much as
a thing that I I've always wanted them
you know you know how kids all right
into their credit to like no we're not
going to buy that for you need to save
up and buy for yourself and at first I
was sad you know I just wanted it now
instagram fication and being like the
child that I was but then i shouldnt
realize that I was gonna get skateboard
unless i actually did save up the money
and so every week i would save up the
money and save up money saving money and
learn how much forty dollars was how
much it actually physically meant to me
how much candy that was a lot of candy
and eventually i remember how long it
took me to save up i saved up but i was
so happy i walked into the store I
bought the skateboard and it was so
pumped there's this like croc crocodile
on the on the top there it says Croc and
underneath and we can anything
underneath there's another crocodile or
something under there so it's all pomp
ready
get out and ride the skateboard and I
took it out on the sidewalk where I live
with my parents and couldn't get up and
you know kept lose my balance it kept
falling after that didn't really get on
the skateboard used it a couple more
times to just have my german shepherd
dog pull me I just sat on the skateboard
and took the dog for a walk and she
pulled me I never didn't really use it
after that at all and so I used it maybe
you haven't no five times of my life I
kept it because not that I used it much
but just a message the lesson from my
parents that you need to save up for the
things that you want to buy you need to
appreciate the set that you have you
need to recognize how much something
costs and you gotta realize that hard
work goes into earning the money to be
able to buy the stuff that you want in
life and so that's why this skateboard
is still here I've carried it with me
from place to place to place the place
and over the years as I've moved are
thrown away a lot of the old stuff lotta
stuff I don't use anymore and this one I
just kept for the sentimental value but
also for the story and the lesson and I
hope that I've continue to apply those
lessons an entrepreneur and look forward
to apply those lessons to the next
generation hayden I'm helping him manage
his money at some point and save of
things that he wants so that's the story
of the skateboard in the office hope you
guys enjoy hope you guys have an amazing
weekend thank you guys for watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you soon